y
[Música]
kenia tiene un nuevo presidente la
comisión electoral declaró como ganador
de los comicios a william ruto con menos
de dos puntos porcentuales por encima de
su contendor raila odinga la oposición
denuncia manipulación de votos
se cumple un año desde que los talibanes
se tomaron el poder en kabul la capital
afgana el gobierno declaró fiesta
nacional y sus simpatizantes marcharon
en las calles mientras que la unión
europea pidió por el respeto de los
derechos de las mujeres
un fallo judicial con perspectiva de
género es lo que piden colectivos
feministas en méxico marisela bautista
fue condenada a 25 años de cárcel por
haber matado a su esposo en 2019 su
abogada alega que fue en defensa propia
pues él la iba a atacar con un machete
bienvenidos a las noticias
internacionales aquí en france 24 yo soy
maría clara calle y es un placer
saludarlos
comenzamos en áfrica la comisión
electoral de kenia declaró como nuevo
presidente a william ruto quien ha
criticado a las dinastías políticas de
hecho le ganó por un estrecho margen a
su oponente y cinco veces candidatos
raila odinga el temor es que se
desencadene una ola de violencia como
las que hubo tras los resultados de 2007
y 2017 cuando se alegó manipulación de
votos esta vez no todos los funcionarios
electorales están de acuerdo con el
conteo y ya comenzaron las protestas
minutos antes de que william bruto fuera
declarado próximo presidente de kenia y
justo cuando una multitud comenzó a
cantar estallaron escenas de caos en la
sala de recuento los partidarios del
candidato raila odinga se abrieron paso
hacia el escenario antes de que los
soldados los obligarán a salir de la
sala junto con los diplomáticos y los
observadores los enfrentamientos
estallaron después de que cuatro altos
funcionarios electorales repudiarán el
resultado we can
no podemos hacernos cargo de los
resultados que se van a anunciar debido
a la opacidad con la que se han manejado
which the beatles shopping and go
fue una carrera reñida entre ruth o un
millonario empresario y odinga ex primer
ministro que ya se había presentado a
las elecciones presidenciales en cuatro
ocasiones en su discurso de victoria
ruto prometió no mirar atrás y elogió a
la comisión electoral el pueblo de kenia
ha ganado porque hemos elevado la vara
política el héroe de estas elecciones es
la comisión electoral independiente isie
en el bastión de odinga aquí sumo en el
este de kenia estallaron violentas
protestas con partidarios que denuncian
fraude en la comisión electoral
para crear el sistema y no quieren dar
transparencia
por eso digo que no hay paz en absoluto
desde 2002 todos los resultados de
elecciones presidenciales de kenia han
sido impugnados odinga tiene siete días
para presentar cualquier reclamo contra
los resultados mientras que el tribunal
supremo tendrá 14 días para pronunciarse
los últimos militares franceses que
quedaban en mali salieron del país
después de nueve años de la llamada
'operación marcan con este operativo
francia combate a los insurgentes
islamistas en la región del sahel sin
embargo parís retirada sus tropas luego
de las tensiones con el gobierno militar
maliense ahora su centro de operaciones
será níger dividiendo sus efectivos en
el sahel por dos hasta el final del año
fue el último contingente de soldados
franceses de la operación marcan el
lunes tomaron sus pertenencias y se
marcharon tras las crecientes tensiones
con la junta gobernante la operación de
9 años deja un variado legado pero por
ahora los soldados que parten se
concentran en el peligroso viaje que
tienen por delante tienen sólo unos días
para mover cientos de piezas de equipos
y llevarlas a la base francesa en níger
la delegado debe ser entregada al
ejército maliense así que se van en unas
horas
dejamos este lugar de operaciones en
unas horas
y cómo se siente
como podría decirlo está completo
nuestra misión aquí se ha completado es
muy importante que nos vayamos todos
juntos y con buena salud
con los años la influencia del grupo
estado islámico se ha expandido en el
lado maliense de la frontera con níger
el 7 de agosto 42 soldados valientes
murieron en un ataque yihadista en
testing
mientras se retiran los soldados
franceses prefieren evitar hablar de
política el sentimiento de frustración
es evidente
cuando eres un soldado no puedes pensar
en las decisiones políticas que toma
nuestro gobierno tenemos una misión y
nuestro único objetivo es esa misión no
se pueden mezclar estas cosas
es otro
solo quedan unos pocos vehículos en la
base pronto desaparecerán y con ellos la
presencia del ejército francés en el
país
hoy hace exactamente un año los
talibanes se tomaron el poder en kabul y
con ello retomaron el control de
afganistán
para conmemorarlo el gobierno declaró
fiesta nacional mientras que el país
vive una crítica situación marcada por
la crisis alimentaria bancaria y de
salud la unión europea instó a los
talibanes a que no violen los derechos
de las mujeres de las niñas y de las
minorías
marta moya tiene los detalles
fiesta nacional para celebrar el regreso
del talibán en afganistán los
fundamentalistas islámicos conmemoran
este lunes el primer aniversario de la
toma de kabul la capital que se dio tras
la apertura de retirada de las tropas de
occidente liderada por eeuu el 15 de
agosto de 2021
con la ayuda de dios todo es posible no
éramos conscientes pero hemos llegado
aquí con la ayuda de dios nunca
olvidaremos en nuestra vida la felicidad
de ese día en el que el señor nos dio
tal victoria así que estamos muy
contentos gracias a dios' abalario
estamos muy contentos de haber derrotado
a eeuu todos los compañeros están muy
contentos mi mensaje a las personas que
huyeron al extranjero que son médicos e
ingenieros o que trabajaban para el
gobierno anterior es que vuelvan a su
país los brazos del emirato islámico
están abiertos para ellos los
necesitamos
pese a las celebraciones en las calles
para muchos en el país es de lunes están
lejos de ser festivo en el último año
afganistán se ha visto sumido en una
galopante crisis alimentaria de la mitad
de los 38 millones de afganos vive bajo
el umbral de la pobreza el sector
bancario está hundido y el 60% de la
ayuda humanitaria extranjera no ha
llegado además enfermedades como el
cólera han rebrotado en el sur del país
en esta degradación a todas las escalas
las mujeres han sido asimismo las
grandes perjudicadas con un borrado casi
total de sus derechos
y realmente durante este año se han
producido cambios negativos en la vida
de todos los afganos especialmente para
las mujeres y yo soy una de ellas me han
impedido trabajar y todo lo demás la
mayoría de días me siento triste y
desanimado
eso se absorbe químico no eso se va a
llevar en des neta a pesar de sus
promesas iniciales los talibanes
volvieron a implantar la interpretación
más estricta del islam ella caracterizó
la primera llegada al poder entre 1996 y
un día cumple 75 años de haberse
independizado del dominio colonial
británico para conmemorar lo el primer
ministro narendra modi prometió que el
país será una nación desarrollada en los
próximos 25 años la oposición dice que
el estatus de india como democracia ha
decaído bajo el liderazgo de modi
un despliegue de orgullo nacional con el
icónico fuerte rojo de nueva delhi como
telón de fondo el primer ministro indio
narendra modi celebró la resiliencia de
su país en sus 75 años de independencia
y expuso su visión para el próximo
cuarto de siglo
tenemos que convertir a india en una
nación desarrollada durante nuestra vida
los jóvenes de 20 21 25 años que están
aquí delante de mí los jóvenes de mi
país cuando vivía celebré los 100 años
de independencia tendrán entre 50 y 55
años lo que significa que el periodo
dorado de sus vidas los 20-25 años de
sus vidas es el momento de hacer
realidad los sueños de indiano como pura
carne
a los hogares y las empresas de toda la
india han sido llamadas a enarbolar la
bandera nacional como parte de una
campaña patriótica del gobierno mientras
tanto los partidos de la oposición dicen
que fueron excluidos de las
celebraciones del día y acusan al
gobierno nacionalista de moody de
socavar las libertades democráticas y
religiosas del país no parece que nadie
sea libre todo el mundo quiere aprender
inglés salir al extranjero nadie habla
en hindi entonces como somos libres
tenemos que superar estas barreras
religiosas porque hay muchas minorías
religiosas que sufren en la india y
minorías de casta al mismo tiempo el
propio modi no respondió a las críticas
en un discurso de 80 minutos ni abordó
los tensos lazos de india con vecinos
como pakistán los dos países se
independizaron al mismo tiempo en 1947
tras el fin del dominio colonial
británico y el sangriento período de la
partición pakistán celebró su
independencia durante el fin de semana
el domingo uniformados de ambos países
celebraron una ceremonia conjunta en su
frontera
una nueva delegación de congresistas
estadounidenses viajó a taiwán a pesar
de las tensiones que se dispararon entre
beijing y taipei por la visita de la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu nancy pelosi hace
12 días china respondió que era un
oportunismo político antes de las
elecciones de medio término en el país
norteamericano
doce días después de la polémica visita
de nancy pelosi a taiwán otro grupo de
legisladores estadounidenses llegó sin
previo aviso a las costas de la isla
cinco miembros de una delegación
bipartidista del congreso se reunieron
con la presidenta
wen durante el encuentro se cree que
conversaron sobre comercio seguridad
regional y cambio climático
su visita demuestra que china no puede
impedir que los políticos de cualquier
país visiten taiwán y también envía un
mensaje importante de que eeuu apoya al
pueblo taiwanés
pero beijing lo define como oportunismo
previo a las elecciones de medio término
en estados unidos que se celebrarán en
noviembre y en los que se renueva un
tercio del senado y la totalidad de la
cámara de representantes
el pp quiere manipular la llamada
democracia libertad y derechos humanos
en taiwán por el bien del partido me
parece mejor es decir una affleck
porque eso es solo una bandera para que
el partido movilice el apoyo de la
población local y también obtener algo
de apoyo de washington round washington
dice la visita se produce en medio de
una campaña continua de intimidación
militar de china hacia taiwán beijing
respondió a la visita de nancy pelosi
con una serie de ejercicios militares
sin precedentes alrededor de la isla
cuyo fin había sido anunciado el 10 de
agosto sin embargo el ejército popular
de liberación sigue enviando aviones de
combate y buques de guerra cerca de
taiwán hecho definido por taipei y
washington como un intento de cambiar el
statu quo de taiwán
el presidente de rusia vladimir putin
dijo que está listo para armar con
equipos modernos a sus aliados en todo
el mundo que no se sometan a lo que
calificó como el llamado de occidente
las declaraciones se produjeron durante
la mayor feria militar rusa denominada
arms 2022 allí el jefe de estado señaló
que incluso ofrece armamento hipersónico
que puede superar cualquier escudo
anti-misiles
que ayude estamos listos para ofrecer a
nuestros aliados y socios los tipos de
armas más modernos desde armas de
infantería hasta vehículos blindados
pasando por artillería aviación de
combate o drones en todo el mundo estas
armas son apreciadas por los
profesionales por su fiabilidad su
calidad y sobre todo por su alta
eficiencia casi todas han sido
utilizadas una y otra vez en condiciones
reales de combate en weibo en méjico
colectivos de mujeres y familiares de
marisela lópez protestaron frente al
palacio de justicia pidiendo su
liberación ella fue condenada a 25 años
de cárcel por haber matado a su marido
antes de que éste la atacara la abogada
de la mujer y su defendida no
reaccionaba los muertos habrían sido
ella sus dos hijos y el bebé que llevaba
en el vientre
familiares y colectivos de indígenas
pidieron este lunes la liberación de
maricela lópez bautista se trata de una
mujer indígena tzotzil que el 20 de
noviembre de 2019 mató a su marido éste
estaba afilando su machete borracho y
drogado y ella respondió con un leño la
realidad de los hechos es que marisela
ese día lo que hizo fue defender su vida
la vida del bebé que llevaba en el
vientre porque ella estaba embarazada de
seis meses y la vida de sus otros dos
chiquititos menores de edad el 19 de
abril un juzgado de san cristóbal de las
casas en el sureño estado de chiapas la
condenó a 25 años de prisión los
manifestantes denuncian que no se
tuvieron en cuenta las pruebas que
evidenciaban la continua violencia que
recibía también argumentan que no tuvo
un juicio justo en este sentido en el
caso de marisela es uno de los tantos
casos que existe en mexico de mujeres de
hombres que no han tenido la oportunidad
de tener un intérprete con perspectiva
de género
intercultural méxico vive una crisis de
violencia machista según la onu cada día
son asesinadas 10 mujeres mientras según
organizaciones hay una impunidad entre
el 97 y el 99 por ciento de los casos en
el gobierno de andrés manuel lópez
obrador los feminicidios se han
disparado este ha culpado al
neoliberalismo pero los colectivos
feministas acusan a los recortes en
programas contra la violencia machista
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]